michael is with us in Kansas hey Michael
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how you doing today better than I
deserve what's up I had a question so
I've been working the plan I don't know
for a couple months was able to pay down
1900 student loans realize I got 1/12
that is a little bit absurd so working
on getting rid of that but then the
other issue I'm having with is a he loss
so me and my wife bought her house
before we were married so she put it in
her name and then we ended up getting
married and then we got a HELOC in them
we've taken the money and then up have
upgraded the house and I'm wondering if
it's time to go ahead and refinance and
then put the HELOC in the mortgage in
the same loan with both of us off the
mortgage balance what is the balance on
the HELOC 35 and what's your household
income after taxes I think we're right
around 85 okay and what is the interest
rate on your first mortgage it's around
4 point I think it's 4.6 okay all right
and the balance on your first mortgage
is what 104 right now okay all right
generally what we tell folks is to put
the second mortgages in baby step 2 in
your debt snowball if they are less than
half your annual income and this is your
well you are ready to go ahead sorry the
reason why I was asking is because my
wife also has a student loan that's over
$50,000 so it would I was thinking it
would speed it up if we were to
refinance to 15-year but that's why I
was asking
yeah no it would and it's an okay you
have $50,000 student loan debt and what
other debts do you have other
I have I have the truck which is 18,000
which I'm getting it clean Friday to
start putting pictures up selling it and
I should break even or make 1,500 and
then we've got credit card debt which is
around 20k and then I've got my car
which has got 3000 but I've degrade to
write a check to pay it off and then we
have her car which is 15,000 yeah you
got a lot of debt yeah you're telling me
about it how much do you know how much
you have in savings or investments that
are not in retirement
right now I've got between us both we've
got around 4500 and savings not
including our thousand dollars and so it
was really now they're gonna use to pay
that little car loan off okay yeah but
I'm gonna wait till the truck just in
case if you know I'm turning you really
quicker so yeah if I become upside down
I have enough to cover that then put the
rest in the car agreed that's a good
move
okay yeah if you want to throw that
HELOC into a refi that's fine because
the first mortgage interest rate is high
enough I think you can probably get you
probably save about one percent or maybe
a little more you probably get a three
and a half three and a quarter 15-year
fixed with Churchill mortgage right now
and that would pay off the first
mortgage and roll the second into it if
you've got the equity in the house to do
that and put it all on a near fixed yeah
I'm probably going to do that just
because you're so freaking overwhelmed
with other debt yeah it's it's
frustrating I mean granted I may be able
to work so that's a plus
yeah and and we've got it worked out to
where my wife had to stay home during
the week and that she makes get enough
money on the weekends to make up for it
so we're on to face with child care so I
mean I mean we're doing okay we're just
spending gotta control but luckily we
put the e log into the home so the home
we could sell it today for like 170 if
we wanted to yeah yeah I'm gonna go
ahead and refinance that get rid of that
and the point being you've learned your
lesson you're never going back
and you know how to clean up the you
know clean up to $15,000 card at the
credit cards the student loan debt and
that's gonna be enough work to do for
sure and baby step two yeah I'm with you
let's do this get in touch with
Churchill mortgage they can help you do
that for sure